[Musique]
bonjour Anthony Saint-Léger bonjour à
tous et on va parler aujourd'hui du
départ des troupes françaises du Mali le
rapprochement stratégique entre Bamako
pardon et Moscou et régulièrement un
terreau fertile pour la diffusion de
fausses informations vous allez nous
montrer encore un exemple ce soir
effectivement depuis le 15 août
l'opération barkhane on le sait a pris
fin au Mali et les après des mois de
tension entre Bamako et Paris Bamako qui
dans le même temps a renforcé ses liens
avec Moscou on a pu assister d'ailleurs
à l'arrivée de de mercenaire russe sur
le territoire malien arrivé aussi de
nouveaux équipements militaires russes
sur le territoire malien c'est
précisément ce contexte qui va être
utilisé par plusieurs comptes Facebook
pour partager notamment depuis le mois
d'août cette vidéo que l'on va découvrir
ensemble alors vous en conviendrez la
qualité n'est pas n'est pas très bonne
on distingue un objet vol alors non pas
non identifié mais difficilement
identifiable qui s'avère si on avance un
petit peu la vidéo et bien être un
hélicoptère qui va terminer sa course au
sol s'écraser donc sur le regard des
passants qui sont là voilà pour ce crash
délicataire alors que nous disent les
publications qui le partagent et bien
pour certaines ça ne fait pas de doute
cette cette l'avion promis par la Russie
qui vient de s'écraser c'est aussi le le
commentaire fait par cet autre
internaute en revanche pour d'autres ce
n'est pas tout à fait la même histoire
non cet hélicoptère a été offert selon
cet utilisateur de Facebook par la
France en 2018 sous IBK Ibrahim Boubacar
Keita l'ancien président en malien pour
d'autres également c'est effectivement
un accident qui a eu lieu une il y a une
dizaine d'années avec toujours cette
idée que l'avion ne serait pas
l'hélicoptère en l'occurrence ne serait
pas russe mais français et que donne la
vérification et bien cette vérification
elle se fait en trois étapes on commence
par un moteur de recherche en
l'occurrence Google et on va y indiquer
ces trois mots Mali hélicoptère et cache
qui vont crash pardon qui vont nous
amener à différents articles celui-ci
par exemple ou encore cette autre ou
vous le voyez il y est question d'un
crash d'un hélicoptère à Cathy est noté
cette date 19 janvier 2019 l'article ici
date du 21 janvier 2019 deux jours après
Cathy c'est où c'est ici au nord de
Bamako la capitale malienne voilà pour
la première étape qu'en est-il de la
seconde étape on va se rendre sur
Twitter on va là aussi faire une
recherche par mots clés en l'occurrence
Cathy crash hélicoptère et on va trouver
plusieurs comptes qui vont partager
et bien vous voyez cette vidéo c'est
même image de ce crash et préciser que
l'accident a bien eu lieu à Cathy et
vous noterez là encore la date 19
janvier 2019 20 janvier 2019 pour
celui-ci c'est la deuxième étape mais
surtout sur Twitter on trouve ceci
regardez ce tweet des forces armées
malienne aider d'un communiqué et il est
question d'un hélicoptère Z9 de l'Armée
de l'Air on est le 19 janvier 2019 tweet
qui fait état d'un atterrissage vous
voyez accidentel sur la place d'Armes de
Cathy donc pour ce communiqué voilà pour
les deux prochaines les deux premières
étapes on revient on va faire une
troisième étape c'est celle de la
géolocalisation qui elle vient nous
confirmer que cette vidéo a bien été
tournée sur cette place d'Armes à Cathy
et puis les photos qui ont été publiées
aussi la suite de ce crash notamment
dans différents articles vont nous
donner des indications parce que elles
vont nous confirmer effectivement
effectivement qu'il s'agit bien d'un
airbin Z9 alors l'airbend Z9 c'est un
hélicoptère de combat chinois notamment
grâce à la forme assez particulière de
ce rotor que l'on trouve ici et puis
évidemment cette cocarde aux couleurs du
Mali que l'on retrouve ici également sur
cette photo donc prise après le crash
cette fois il s'agit de véhicules
blindés effectivement plusieurs photos
que l'on a pu voir là encore selon tout
le mois d'août finalement les dernières
semaines essentiellement du mois d'août
plusieurs photos de blindés qui ont été
publiés des différents chats qui ont été
considérés comme des cadeaux faits par
Vladimir Poutine à au Mali c'est
notamment le cas de certains internautes
on peut retrouver vous voyez le terme
cadeau fait à Vladimir Poutine on notera
ici elle a la photo de Vladimir Poutine
et du colonel de transition assimigoïta
et précisément ces publications elles
sont surtout
devenues virales depuis ou après plus
précisément l'entretien téléphonique qui
a eu lieu en août entre le colonel le
transition assimile Goya et Eve Vladimir
Poutine mais que nous dit la
vérification et bien une recherche
d'image inversée c'est assez simple à
faire vous le savez nous renvoie sur une
publication celle-ci qui évoque
effectivement une livraison de 15
blindés de type cougar au Mali mais
notez bien ils ont été offerts par les
Emirats Arabes Unis et non par la Russie
et cette publication elle date de 2020
on retrouve aussi en faisant des
recherches complémentaires et bien ce
tweet des forces armées manuelles qui
évoquent bien ces blindé de type Kuga
offert par les Émirats arabes unis et on
est bien vous le voyez le 28 janvier
2020 merci beaucoup Anthony Saint-Léger
pour cette recherche ex